foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
Banks and I lead developer products and
community at Google my team and I love
empowering developers to build
Innovations for the future
which leads me to the theme of next this
year
today
meet tomorrow
to tell you a little more about how we
think about tomorrow my friends and I at
Google Cloud will share top technology
predictions for where we believe the
cloud is headed over the next three
years
each one of us will share the one
prediction We Believe will be true by
the end of 2025.
my prediction is by the end of 2025
developers will start with with neural
inclusive design we'll see a 5x growth
and user adoption in their first two
years in production
my prediction is that by the end of 2025
4 out of five Enterprise developers we
use some form of curated open source
and my prediction is that by the end of
2025 90 of security operations workflows
will be automated and managed as code
my prediction is by the end of 2025 AI
is going to be the primary driver for
moving to a four day work week
prediction is that by the end of 2025 90
of data will be actionable in real time
I predict that by the end of 2025 the
barriers between transactional and
analytical workloads will disappear
my prediction is by the end of 2025 over
half of cloud infrastructure decisions
will be automated based on
organization's usage patterns to meet
performance and reliability needs
my prediction is that by the end of 2025
three out of four developers will lead
with sustainability as their primary
development principle
my prediction for you today is that by
the end of 2025 over half of all
organizations using public Cloud we're
actually going to freely switch their
primary Cloud as a result of all these
new multi-cloud capabilities available
my prediction is that by the end of 2025
over half of all business applications
will be built by users who do not
identify as professional developers
today
foreign